I have a core Rule and it's this I only
speak if I can be heard
and so if I see a loved one A friend of
mine just doing something so dumb with
their money
all right they're just acting like
idiots
or a buddy I don't have any friends like
this but let's pretend I did like I had
a buddy that was like man I've really
met this girl and we're kind of like
we're not hooking up or like we go have
drinks once a week or something like
that and he's married to a friend of
mine
um
I
if they say hey man what do you think
about that
or am I crazy bro you just opened the
door like a vampire and invited me in
I'm coming in I'm Gonna Give You full
picture but if you're being done with
your money and you don't ask my I'm not
just gonna start I'm just not gonna
start
giving you wisdom or advice or what I
think is the right thing to do I used to
do that all the time and I
um almost became abusive with that